اقتحمت قوه من جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مخيم عسكر شرق مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
فجرا وحاصرت منزل عائله عبد الفتاح خروشه
منفذ عمليه حوار شهر الماضي والتي قتل
فيها مستوطنين
قوه الاسرائيليه بعمليه مسح هندسي للمنزل
تمهيدا لهدمه وافاد شهود عيان باندلاع
مواجهه بين القوه الاسرائيليه ومحتاجين
فلسطينيين قبل انسحابها من المنطقه
في غضون ذلك قال نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتقلت 25
فلسطينيا في انحاء مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه الليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم وبحسب
بيان لنادي الاسير الفلسطيني فان حملت
الاعتقال ترى كزت في بلدات ام مروه ومخيم
الفوار في محافظه الخليل وفي مدينه نابلس
وبلده يعبد جنوب جنين ومخيم عقبه جبر في
اريحا حيث دامت قوه عسكريه من جيش
الاحتلال العديد من المنازل وعبثت
بمقتنياتها واقتادت الشبان الى معسكرات
التحقيق بتهمه مقاومه الاحتلال
من رام الله ينضم الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد ارحب بك اذا اخر ما
رصدته على الارض وربما القراءه ايضا في
تفعيل القبه الحديثيه من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي اليوم
كل ما ورد في الخبر الذي قراتوه يشير الى
ان السلطات الاسرائيليه ممثله بجيش
الاحتلال ومستوطنيه وحكومه اقصى اليمين
المتطرف والمرتدين المشددين تدفع نحو مزيد
من التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه هي تروج
الى انها تريد ان تهدئه او تخفيف الضغط
وفي الاراضي الفلسطينيه مع حلول شهر رمضان
المبارك غدا وايضا الاعياد عيد الفصح
المسيحي وعيد الفصحى اليهودي خلال
الاسابيع المقبله لكن على الارض هي ماضيه
في سياستها التصعيديه والغائها لقرار
بفك الارتباط من خلال السماح بالعوده
المستوطنين الى اربع مستوطنات في الشماليه
الضفه الغربيه ابقى شعورا وتقديرات لدى
الفلسطينيين على كافه المستويات ان لا
جدوى ولا فائده من اي اتفاقات تبرم مع
اسرائيل حتى لو كانت بضمانات دوليه
وهذا مؤشر على ان كل الاجتماعات وما
شاع حول تفاهمات في العقبه ومن ثم في شرم
الشيخ هذه كلها لا يبدو انها ستكون نافذه
لان ما يجري على الارض من تصعيد ويخدم
سياسه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
بتركيبتها المعروفه للجميع
الطائره او المسيره على الحدود مع غزه هذا
التطور حصل في النصف ساعه الاخيره وكان
جراء سماع عدويه الانفجارات فتبين ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد رصد مسيره قادمه من
قطاع غزه وقام باعتراضها من خلال اطلاق
صواريخ القبه الحديديه